for a week now with everything happening
in cuba um
you know no democrats basically have
said anything bad about communism if
anything they've subtly endorsed it or
not said anything like aoc and
omar and bernie and the rest of them but
yesterday
biden actually did say the c word and he
kind of condemned it in his sleepy way
take a look at this clip communism is a
fail system
universally fail system and uh
i don't see socialism as a very useful
substitute but that's another story cuba
is a uh unfortunately a failed state and
repressing
uh their citizens
boy inspirational huh that guy could he
wake up a lot of people um all right
let's just do this real quick one one
shot for each you
i mean that he choked that out to me
like there's just nothing behind it and
they are socialists and that's not that
far from communist
david am i over stating this yeah i mean
joe biden has been in political life for
so many decades
and and you know i think his uh his his
brain is mush at this point
so sometimes an old script would pop
will pop into his head maybe from 1985
or something like that
and um i've got a feeling that's what
happened here
um i know i'm i'm pretty sure that uh
that they
they uh they denied him a scoop of ice
cream
uh that evening that at the uh at the
white house and you know had him had him
sit alone in a corner after uh after
giving that speech
right when trump has ice cream it's
national lose biden gets ice cream
and it's like the greatest thing ever uh
rogan i mean at this point do you think
they are the democrats in effect are
socialists like is there any meaningful
distinction between the average democrat
at this point
and a socialist which of course is only
a stone's throw away from a communist
you know any time i call democrats
socialists or communists i always get
people in the comments do you even know
what communism is do you know what
socialism is
i think they're just flagrant
authoritarians and the economic system
is really just
secondary to the crushing government
power that
they want to enact on you know these
peasants that inhabit
this beautiful country you know we went
from ronald reagan mr gorbachev
tear down this wall right in his face to
uh hey mr
castro could you uh you know maybe sort
of kind of be nicer
socialism isn't so good i mean come on
ron you're not acting as rogan's lawyer
in this capacity are they socialists
oh i think you're muted ron
you see what they did they're trying to
silence me they're not socialists
they are first of all depends on who we
mean by they
the democrats who are in charge of the
democratic party are not socialists
they're not interested in the
redistribution of the wealth
they have a great deal of that wealth
they're not interested in
the change of management or
or ownership of the means of production
they don't none of them has even read
marks
they are crony capitalists what they
are doing is playing to their left-wing
base
an activist and donor base which
you know as being a bolshevik style
party this is the one thing that the
democrats will always have
over the republicans which is that they
have party and message
discipline and the rule among democrats
is
no enemies to the left ever so whatever
it takes
yeah it's actually a great point like
pelosi is not willing to give up her
hundreds of millions of dollars in the
ton of money she made on
wall street this week so she's not a
socialist in that regard she's just
messaging to those guys